nancy marsolais a vu son rêve de fonder
une famille repoussée en raison de la
pandémie
elle ne peut pas devenir enceinte tant
qu'elle n'aura pas subi l'ablation de
fibromes utérins et cette opération a
été annulé c'est sûr qu'en n'ayant 40
ans ce soir que l'horloge tourne et et
le temps tome gti par dessus la reprise
des chirurgies non urgentes et un
soulagement pour elle mais elle sait
qu'elle devra se montrer patiente
malheureusement on est impuissant parce
que c'est même si je vais m'asseoir dans
la phase du médecin la rue devant leur
moi je veux une batte ya rien qui vaille
arié qui vont bouger
québec estime que 68000 chirurgie ont
été reportées depuis le début de la
crise
la fédération des médecins spécialistes
du québec parle plutôt de 81000 pour de
nombreux patients
il est minuit moins une selon la
coalition priorité cancer au québec
partout pour que ces gens lot on parle
de chaises et les gens qui attend pas
trop longtemps et des concerts qui
étaient opérable ou curatif deviennent
palliatifs et que ça soit trop tard les
spécialistes heroes par priorité mais il
faudra mettre les bouchées doubles pour
rattraper le temps perdu
tous les patients qui sont opérés ci
passe par un comité collégiale de
docteur pour s'assurer que les bons
patients sont opérés au bon moment qui a
pas de préjudice
il va falloir considérer que je pense
que c'est une stratégie comme ça qu'il
faut voir
pour la ministre de la santé et
confiante que la cadence augmentera au
fil des semaines plus de personnel
disponible par exemple mais aussi des
ententes avec des cliniques privées des
centres médicaux spécialisés allongé des
heures de travail la fin de semaine le
soir nancy marsolais de son côté demeure
confiante je peux pas passer à côté de
son rêve de maternité est encore
atteignables ici valérie michaela bayne
radio canada montréal